(upbeat music)
- Hello, we are continuing with our survey
of the national birds of
Latin American countries.
And we are here and
continuing with the Caribbean.
That this tray here has
the national birds of most
we're missing maybe a couple
of the Caribbean islands.
And I apologize for that.
So start here with the northern,
with the Greater Antilles
and the Island of Cuba,
Cuba selected the trogon.
This is a beautiful species
and even has the colors
matching the Cuban flag.
The Cuban name is tocororo or tocororo,
that's onomatopoeic.
The bird actually does
have a vocalization,
that sounds like this.
And the tail is entirely unique.
There is no trogon species
with this sort of nicely curved tail.
And the related species of trogon
is found on the Island of Hispaniola.
So here is the Hispaniolan trogon.
This one was chosen as a national bird
by the country of Haiti
and there they call it
Calecon Rouge or Calcon Rouge.
And uh
here this is a male
and same as with the Cuban trogon species
that is found in forested,
but more open habitats,
a nest in three cavities,
sometimes abandoned with pecker
holes and relatively common
both species are still in in
good shape, not endangered.
On the same Island of Hispaniola,
the country of the Dominican Republic,
Republica Dominicana chose the palmchat
to be their national bird.
And the reason for this is
that this is really part of the landscape.
One of the most common birds
I recently visited the country
of the Dominican Republic
and got to see them
everywhere and their nests.
Their massive fortresses of sticks
that are communal nests
found throughout the country
on telephone poles and in
trees, but mostly in palms
sometimes even on the rocks.
I have seen this and this bird is a unique
kind of enigmatic fellow
genetically it's closest related
to North American waxwings
but it's a single member of it's family.
So it's a good choice for a national bird.
Then if we move to the
next island to the East,
to Puerto Rico.
This bird the spindalis, was
chosen as a national bird.
Let me see it's called
reinita mora in Puerto Rico
or reina mora, or sigua
another name I found.
And in English, it used to be
called stripe-headed tanager.
For obvious reason, it
has a lot of stripes,
but now we know that it's
not really closely related
to tanagers.
It's a unique Caribbean lineage
and there are four species
on different islands.
And this one is endemic to Puerto Rico.
Then moving over to Jamaica.
In Jamaica this gorgeous hummingbird
was chosen as a national bird.
It's called by Jamaicans,
Dr. Bird or Dr. Hummingbird.
I couldn't find a good
explanation for this name, but
the male has spectacularly long tail
and in flight must be a pleasure to see
and be strangely enough,
birds in the Eastern part of
the country have black bills
and the rest of the country, red bills.
This one here is a bit faded
but it used to be a red billed bird.
And female is without
this ornamental feathers
in the tail and a little bit smaller
but it's still a common
bird, not endangered.
Then, let's maybe look at, oh
yeah, maybe here the parrots.
So three different Caribbean countries
insular countries chose parrots
for their national birds.
Let's maybe look at this one first.
This is the largest of the
member of the genus amazona
imperial parrot, appropriately named.
And this great bird is endemic
to the Island of Dominica.
And there it's called
it's called sisserou.
It's an endangered species.
There are only fewer than 200
individuals left in the wild
and not too many in captivity.
So this one has to be watched
and cared for managed carefully.
The neighboring Island of
Saint Lucia chose their own
amazon totally differently
colored but still quite colorful.
And also it's not very common.
Let's see did the name they chose for it
the local name is jacquot or jacquot,
um I think it is jacquot.
And in this case there
are fewer than 500 birds
left in the wild.
And both of these birds
are in the mountains,
in the interior of the Island.
So hopefully inaccessible
and hopefully the habit will be preserved.
And then the third of these amazons
of the Caribbean,
this parrot here called
Saint Vincent parrot
on of the Island of Saint
Vincent and the Grenadines
has two different color
morphs, green and yellow.
And here we have a
representative of the green
and these birds are a
little bit more common
not as endangered as the other two,
I mentioned before
but still it's a relatively
small populations.
Population is small Island
and a little lower in this
case, not in the mountains.
And then,
we go to
Island of Aruba
where interestingly two birds were chosen
for the national bird.
First, it was the shoco,
locally named burrowing owl
subspecies endemic to Aruba.
And
the second one more recently,
this little parakeet,
brown throated parakeet which
there is called prikichi.
Probably onomatopoeic
probably after the call.
And I guess the reason for the
switch was to bring attention
to this bird that maybe is
in more need of conservation.
And that's why the country
brings attention to it.
And finally, no not finally,
but we are traveling further south.
This is now Trinidad and two birds
here because Trinidad Island
has the scarlet ibis chosen
as their national bird.
And the Island of Tobago
has this chachalaca.
This is one of the guans,
chicken like birds.
And this one is called rufous tail tailed,
rufus caudatus in Latin,
because of this nice rufous tipped tail.
And also the belly is chestnut colored.
This specimen is maybe not the nicest.
The ibis is a common
site throughout Trinidad,
and it's a marsh bird
nesting in big colonies
and often seen in flocks,
traveling from the feeding
grounds to the, to their nests.
And I then will move
to these two big birds.
So the Island of Barbados
and the country of Barbados,
let me see here
chose the brown pelican
as their a national bird.
So here, maybe actually this view
this is a species that is
pretty widely distributed
not only in Caribbean islands
but also in South Southern United States.
And it's a colonial nester that I mean,
everybody talks about egg thinning
and endangerment of raptors,
but this bird also suffered quite a bit
in 1950s, 1970s from the use of DDT
and
from
the pesticides and egg thinning.
And finally,
here is the bird,
chosen by the country of uh
Antigua and Barbuda.
And this is the magnificent
magnificent frigatebird
sometimes called man of war.
This is one of the seabirds
famous for its behavior
of stealing food from other birds.
It can steal fish or some other,
but they can also catch their own fish.
They can pick up for
example, snap, a flying fish
from the air.
And this bird here is a male.
In life, this would be a
bright red inflatable sack.
And the males on the breeding grounds,
would inflate this to attract females.
Females don't have this inflatable sack.
And I will end by saying that
a one cool kind of record
that this bird also beats is
that a frigatebird's skeleton
is lighter than the feathers.
If you actually plucked all
the feathers and combined them,
the skeleton is so primatized
and so light fused,
that it's lighter.
So that's a pretty good choice
also for the national bird.
(upbeat music)